yeah hey everyone I'm Alex I work for a
great company called airship like I just
said they're based in the companies
based in Birmingham but I live in
Chattanooga
I want to first start off in a more
personal note by just kind of saying how
thankful I am to be here so I've
attended Chaney react for the past two
years and very very honored very
thankful to be able to present over the
course of our presenting this year over
the course of those two years a lot has
obviously changed within the react and
react Native community particularly
regarding typescript so as I'm sure
everyone in the room can attest to it's
kind of impossible to browse Twitter
blogs and not see people talking about
switching over to typescript so like if
your timeline is anything like mine
you've probably seen things like this
where you know you got Kent C Dodds
talking about it
Dan Abramov talking about it Raphael
who's somewhere around here
he's been tweeting about it for awhile
even the infinite red crew there they're
all in on type surfing and talking about
converting projects over so if you're
anything like me you might be might get
a little bit of FOMO any time these
people tweet about things that you're
not currently doing in your work
so fortunately at heirship we've moved a
handful of projects over to typescript
and along the way I've found a
repeatable compartmentalized pattern to
approach this type of conversion from
regular JavaScript to typescript so if
you aren't quite as familiar with what
types ripped is unfortunate we don't
really have a lot of time to go into any
sort of detail but essentially
typescript is a superset of JavaScript
so it's built on top of the JavaScript
you already know it just has some
additional features that make it unique
such as types so this close relationship
with JavaScript is what makes a
conversion a lot more manageable than
you might think
so throughout the process today we're
gonna be using an existing project of
mine which may be a bit arbitrarily
simple but I know strangely important to
society right now I don't know but
nonetheless the project's can help
convey some ideas that are this
conversion is going to
or happen so one of the great things
about typescript is that it is very
configurable so we can make it as strict
or as loose as we want in terms of type
checking so a common problem I've seen
is people trying to convert projects
over to typescript and basically trying
to do it all in one go with the strict
configuration so like the initial setup
of that is is way more daunting than it
probably should be so that's what we're
splitting up into three particular steps
so each of the three steps that we're
going to talk about today could be the
end of your typescript conversion and
you'll get a certain level of benefits
at each at each step so we're gonna go
from the loosest configuration to the
strictest and then you can make your own
judgments about what makes sense for you
and your team so on to step one we're
calling it just make it work so the goal
for the first step is simply to get our
code running again without having to
make any significant changes to the code
itself so we'll need to set up a basic
config file so that type strip can know
what rules we want to follow or not
follow and as I mentioned before this
will be the loosest configuration of
typescript so here's an example TS
config file for react native this is
this would live in the root of your
project so it has a couple of rules
we're gonna gloss over for the sake of
time but I want to focus on one in
particular setting no implicit any to
false will allow implicit in ease so
these implicit in ease are used in
typescript when it can't infer a
particular type of a variable so we're
allowing these in the first step just to
get our code to our project to compile
with typescript without making any
significant changes to the code itself
so the next thing we need to do is is
just gonna involve changing the file
extensions over from Jas to TS and tsx
so one slight gotcha with typescript is
that anytime you want to use JSX in your
code the file has to end and dot tsx
which is a bit stricter than how
javascript might work so if you have a
larger project that isn't just to a to
screen app with cats manually changing
this over could be a bit more daunting
but luckily there's an excellent tool
and perfectly title tool called
js2 TS converter that handles changing
these file extensions over as well as
parsing the file for any JSX that that
might be in the in the file and naming
that with the dot TSX extension in that
case so once we're done changing the
file extensions over we're working with
a real type script project okay
however there's probably a decent
possibility that you might still be
seeing a few errors which is actually a
good thing so in my example with the cat
app I was really rushed for time you
know had investors calling me they were
like we need this cat app right now and
I was like probably need to write more
tests and they're like no we have to
have the cats and so I had to rush into
the App Store unfortunately I had a few
fundamental JavaScript issues that went
unnoticed before but types trip is now
able to identify those errors
immediately and give me some feedback as
to what the problem is so in this
example you can see I have a log error
function at the top it expects two
arguments however when I'm using it at
the bottom I'm only passing it one
so type strip is able to bring it to my
attention immediately and tell me what
argument I'm missing in the in the call
so once I fix these issues the project
should run successfully and we're
officially done with step one so now for
step two we're gonna be explicit so the
next step in the process is going to be
to only allow explicit innies by
toggling no implicit in e to true so
this means that instead of typescript
defaulting to in any type when it can't
use type inference it's actually gonna
give it a compile error so all the
places that the compiler was
automatically adding it any type will
now require you to give it a type or
explicitly say it's an inning which
contrary to pop contrary to popular
belief using any types is fine use them
when you need to
don't don't feel any pressure to not or
to not use any x'
so you can see here in this example i'm
saying that this function expects an
image ID and as a string and a value as
a boolean so i would then need to go
through the application and do the same
sort of thing by specifying the argument
types for
the different functions and methods of
whatnot so this is also a good time to
start creating the common object types
that are used throughout the project and
adding them more possible so here's a
cat object type you can see all the
properties that it has I'm then going to
use this type all over my project any
time I'm dealing with a cat in the data
so I'm just going to add it as the type
in the function another part of this
step will be to bring in types from
third-party libraries that don't provide
type script types so if the library is
written in regular JavaScript we can
still add types on top of it that
describe its usage so there's an
excellent open-source resource called
definitely typed that contains types for
many popular libraries such as you know
lodash or react or react native itself
even so you just need to add at types
before the library name and then just
add it to your projects appendices so
this step will probably take a bit
longer than that first step so but the
efforts you spend doing this will pay
off dividends once you start adding to
your codebase and especially when you
start refactoring your code so like I
mentioned before any of these steps
could be the end of your types of
conversion so we have many projects at
heirship that ended up somewhere in the
middle of steps one and two and honestly
there are a lot better off because of
that so however if you want to keep
pushing on and go all in on typescript
there's only one more step so we'll call
it strict mode so the last step involves
enabling the strict setting which simply
adds a number of strict rules for
typescript to adhere to even though the
setting might sound a bit invasive and
over-the-top these rules really just
enforced good JavaScript patterns in
your code so one of the rules enabled
with strict is straight null checks so
this was created to ensure that you
don't try to use the variable that could
potentially be null or undefined so for
example we have this cat type from
earlier and you can see that the age
property is optional so you can see that
it's optional because it has a question
mark after the key which means that it
could be
undefined so when I try to run the to
string method on age types was going to
give me or type screen to give me an
error so I need to make sure age exists
first before trying to run that method
otherwise I'm just gonna return a
default string so depending on the
project there might actually not be that
much refactoring for step three at all
if you're already writing safe and safe
JavaScript and there's a high likelihood
that types rip is going to agree as well
so and that's pretty much it so we've
taken a standard react native JavaScript
project and successfully converted over
to type strip and three contain steps so
first we added a basic type script
configuration and simply change the file
extension is over then we got more
explicit about the types we're using
throughout the application by turning
off implicit in ease and creating our
own common types as well as bring in
third-party types and then finally we
enabled this strict configuration which
further ensures that we're writing safe
and air resilient code now I I know the
title of this lightning talk might have
been a bit misleading because a full and
complete conversion to type script with
a robust project that isn't just two
screens about cats you know could take
days weeks or even months to
successfully pour it over but I want to
reiterate the fact that types rip can
add value to your project you know at
any step no matter if you're just
changing the file extensions over and
setting up the config or you're a
hundred percent integrated so I hope
this quick talk has helped clear up some
questions you might have had but as you
might imagine there's a lot more to this
process then then we can fit in in ten
minutes so please come find me
afterwards if you have any more
questions about typescript and react
native so thank you very much for having
me
[Applause]
[Music]